[Music]
you're gonna knock them dead at the
veterans hall tonight hon you thank you
absolutely now get ready and stop
hogging the mirror right and this is
where you create your character by
simply selecting part of the face and
sculpting such a cute nose what do you
think huh beard or no beard
we're gonna speed up time here and show
you just how easy and powerful this is
to create all new characters by just
sculpting and making changes wherever
you want in the face no series of
sliders hey my turn big guy and of
course you can play as a female
however you leave the menu as is who
you'll play and this is an entirely
dynamic system it's the same system we
use to create all of the games NPCs we
even generate a baby
based on the couple you make thanks
cosmic nuka-cola ice cold sugar bombs
100 percent daily value of sugar good
money
vault-tec kali vault-tec remind me again
why we're about you sir and helping
secure your future
you see vaulteq is the foremost builder
of state-of-the-art underground fallout
shelters vaults if you will but there's
room for my entire family right of
course of course
miners you robot naturally in fact
you're already cleared for entrance it's
just a matter of gara fiying some
information
[Applause]
wonderful that's everything
just gonna walk this over to the vault
congratulations on being prepared for
the thanks again hmm
it's peace of mind that's worth a little
paperwork right your codsworth say my
name that isn't for the demo we actually
have recorded around a thousand of the
most popular names for him to say how
are the two most important men in my
life doing spin the mobile a bit he
loves that
[Music]
reports of nuclear detonations in the
Orkin disfigure my god
we we need to get to the vault now I've
got Shawn let's go
almost there I love you both of you we
love you too hold on now we're not going
to be spoiling or talking about the game
story tonight but you do survive and get
lowered into the vault events transpire
but you then emerge 200 years later as
the sole survivor of vault 111
this is an enormous dynamic world where
you can create any kind of character you
want go where you want and do whatever
you want
player freedom remains our absolute
number one goal
[Music]
this is running on a next-generation
version of our creation engine features
full physical based rendering as well as
dynamic volumetric lighting
codsworth you're you're still here so
other people can still be alive - it's
worse than I thought
no no that's not possible
I wasn't after that long what fool yeah
sure I need a minute a thing like that
even our dialogue is dynamic it's not a
mode you're locked into you can play it
in first-person you can play it in third
person you can walk away whenever you
want you shoot him in the face if you
want
you're all by yourself
you want to come with me pal okay then
let's stick together hey head over there
and yes you can give the dog commands by
simply pointing at things in the
environment activating them it's all
contextual grab that
ready to get back out there it is from
here that you'll explore the most
ambitious and detailed game world that
we have ever made culminating in the
massive ruins of downtown Boston
you
[Music]